hola que tal el expresidente carlos mesa
candidato de comunidad ciudadana ha
enviado su felicitación para el binomio
ganador y les ha deseado éxito y ha
dicho que como le corresponde a una
oposición democrática va a estar
siguiendo sus actos de manera vigilante
el que no ha querido pronunciarse ni
reconocer la victoria de luís arce ha
sido luís fernando camacho que ha
terminado tercero en estas elecciones
por el contrario sus seguidores han
mantenido protestas los últimos días en
varias ciudades del país y sobre todo en
santacruz incluso ellos amenazan con un
paro cívico porque creen que ha habido
fraude electoral pero hay que decir que
las misiones de observación han señalado
que ha sido un proceso electoral
transparente y sin acciones fraudulentas
cuáles son los retos del nuevo gobierno
me dijo
el principal reto es sacar al país de la
crisis económica en la que se encuentra
producto de la pandemia de hecho los
informes oficiales hablan de una caída
del pib del 11% y se dice que el déficit
podría llegar incluso hasta el 12 por
ciento en ese marco el presidente electo
ha hecho ya algunos anuncios respecto a
las primeras medidas que va a tomar por
ejemplo ha dicho que se va a aplicar un
impuesto a la riqueza que se va a
reducir el iva para las compras con
tarjetas de crédito y además que se va a
pagar un bono denominado contra el
hambre de 144 dólares
mary hablemos de evo morales que
escenarios son posibles con el
expresidente boliviano
luízar se ha marcado una moderada
distancia con el ex presidente evo
morales ha señalado que no va a ser
parte de su gobierno y que probablemente
va a estar muy ocupado defendiéndose de
todos los juicios que existen en su
contra por lo tanto no ha dicho si es
que él permitirá o le pedirá que regrese
al país en todo caso se puede decir que
existen algunas discrepancias dentro del
partido movimiento al socialismo pues
por ejemplo los sectores cocaleros
quieren que el ex presidente regrese de
inmediato pero hay otros sectores que
consideran que no es prudente todavía es
un debate que todavía no está cerrado en
el movimiento al socialismo este partido
ahora está más abocado a realizar la
transición hacia el nuevo gobierno